and here to discuss more on the
indictments is CBS News justice reporter
Paula Reed she's in our Washington
bureau Paula good morning good morning
Paula what can you tell us about some of
the principals named in this indictment
let's start with Yevgeniy preggos in he
is a Russian businessman with close ties
to Vladimir Putin now according to court
documents he helped to fund the internet
research agency that launched these
operations against the u.s. now the
other defendants are accused of working
for that agency to effectively operate
as a troll farm so these were people who
spoke English well enough to be credible
as they pumped out these messages on
social media we also know from the court
documents that some of these defendants
traveled here to the United States to
collect intelligence and then to launch
actual events rallies and and even some
self-defense training and prigogine
otherwise known as Putin's chef it does
have close ties to Putin obviously but
the the Kremlin and the Russian
government has not been implicated
there's no wrongdoing alleged by the
Trump campaign so where does that lead
the investigation going forward Paula
well this lays out a way to possibly
charge folks here in the United States
the documents specifically say that the
Russians worked with Americans here on
the ground so the question for robert
muller is whether or not any of those
americans actually knew who they were
working with and what those russians
were up to because if you knowingly
worked with the russians to sway votes
or to put on any of these events you
could be charged with conspiracy paula
tell us who Richard Pineda was he pled
guilty to selling bank accounts to two
Russians that's right he is a
self-described digital marketing
strategist and according to court
documents he helps provide services to
people to get around those security
features are those identification
requirements for eBay or Amazon now
according to court documents he
purchased stolen banking information
before selling it to clients and while
his lawyers say he had no knowledge in
this specific instance of who he was
working with or what they were up to
clearly selling other people's personal
information is
crime and we're learning about more
charges this morning against Paul
Manafort what are they well it's new
possible charges though new evidence was
revealed in a court filing late last
night they revealed that they have new
evidence that Paul Manafort they have
committed bank fraud in addition to all
the charges he's already facing know
according to the court documents he
allegedly used doctored profit and loss
statements she was essentially
overstating how much money he was
actually being paid as a consultant this
has been a consistent theme throughout
the mana for prosecution the reason he
doesn't actually have an official bail
agreement is because the court can't
figure out how much he is worth because
when you look at all the documents he
signed in the months leading up to his
arrest estimates of his net worth just
varied so greatly it's unclear whether
or not Special Counsel will use this new
evidence to pursue other charges but
they have a lot of time because his
trial is not expected to start until the
fall it is stunning to think there are
now four Trump associates you've either
been charged or pled guilty as part of
this investigation Paula Reed our thanks
to you